et c'est bien ce que je vous dis c'est
bien ce que je regrette ça a été
beaucoup expliqué avant les élections et
depuis les élections
la capacité d écoute de construction de
majorités d'idées de la part de la
majorité actuelle n'existe pas ou
n'existe quasiment que marginalement
facialement je vous prends un exemple le
gouvernement est en train de commettre
beaucoup de bêtises de préparer beaucoup
de bêtises et de dire de gros mensonges
sur le logement et la réforme du
logement
il ya besoin d'une réforme du logement
ça a complètement dérapé
on dépense des milliards et des
milliards et en même temps on a une
crise du logement qui ne cessent pas il
commet des bêtises nous sommes sur tous
les bancs politique beaucoup à dire
attention là vous vous trompez il ya des
technocrates qui décide des choses qui
sont absurdes
le gouvernement est il capable d'écouter
c'est un défi nous on n'est pas après
tout je pourrais tirer dessus tous les
matins en disant c'est une lutte c'est
nul c'est parce que je dis je ne vais
pas cette erreur parce que c'est les
français qui payent la facture